the minimalists want to help you avoid
impulse purchases that's why we created
five questions to ask before buying
which is now
a wallpaper for your smartphone now
you'll always have a reminder when
you're getting ready to purchase
something new
head on over to theminimalists.com
before
to download your free wallpaper today
uh what are the unexpected upsides and
downsides of
communal living for chris
yeah so upsides um i definitely notice
that you know some of the usual coping
mechanisms completely lose their appeal
so social media being one why is it that
people just keep
scrolling and scrolling and scrolling is
it that they're trying to find the
others is that the
itch that they're trying to scratch you
know i'm looking for big butts usually
[Laughter]
i think it's that like longing to belong
you know you're trying to find a friend
like
yes that completely loses its appeal
when there are actual friends there you
know like all the time like for real
it's like that's definitely one
i mean so the word unexpected is like
kind of the caveat here right there was
a lot of things i expected but
unexpected i guess that's sort of a
relative thing it might be
you know unexpected to me but not
unexpected to somebody else
what would be unexpected for a lot of
people to hear about your current living
situation
uh you know the boundaries thing that
you mentioned earlier like i've been
really surprised how hard
it is to enforce those in real life so
you like
what like so i mean so the blue light
thing is like a really good example
actually so
for maybe people don't know that are
listening that blue light
um suppresses the production of a
hormone called melatonin and melatonin
is like the starting gun for sleep you
can think of it like that so blue light
comes from any of our screens basically
yeah exactly so normally during the day
it comes from the sun right and then the
sun goes down
and then melatonin goes up and then you
go to sleep but you can interfere with
that
with the electric lighting on your
ceiling or with screens or whatever
and of course you know like a decision i
make with the light switch
is like kind of a decision i make for
everyone right like it's not
sure necessarily mine and only my
decision to make
but you know maybe someone else that
you're living with
doesn't know that and i'm like really
sensitive about preaching
ancestral health or anything else like i
really don't want to say anything unless
i absolutely have to
or somebody asks you know like i
work with a psychologist and he said to
me once the the difference between a
guest and a pest is an invitation right
like if someone invites you then
sure you can talk about this stuff but
you know maybe it is a boundary like
sleep
seems to me to be a keystone behavior
for everything else like if you're not
sleeping well
nothing else goes well right not diet
choices not movement not nothing else
so it's like seems like a really hard
and fast thing i should have as a
boundary
but it's really hard to say to someone
you know what
keep that light switch turned off like
that has been like a really surprising
thing to me
how hard it is to enforce that boundary
and i think it is mine to enforce i
think a
boundary is a bit like a no trespassing
sign you know when you're
trying to keep people off of your
property it's your responsibility to put
up those no trespassing signs and it's
really your responsibility to try and
keep people out you know you can't
expect people to
like know where the boundary is without
you putting up a sign you know so it's
really on you to enforce those
boundaries and it's hard
yeah yeah anything else unexpected um
i think the other one was really what my
yoga teacher neighbor said that
about love and you know alison gopnik
wrote in the philosopher baby is another
really good book um
that we you know we we love the children
that we care for was the first thing she
said
and what she meant by that is you don't
love this one but not that one because
you share dna with them
you love them because you spent a lot of
time looking after them that's all there
is to it you know so if you spend a lot
of time looking after somebody else's
kid you'll love that kid too
and then conversely those kids that
they they love you in return right so
they just love the people who look after
them
yes now the answer but there is also a
biological component to that as well oh
yeah absolutely especially with the
mother
yeah absolutely absolutely but do you
find with your own kids versus other
kids that are
in on your land um i mean obviously you
love your
your kids more that word love is i i
actually don't think you love them more
but you
prefer them more maybe the the better
word uh
i think love is is sort of ubiquitous
and and and
most people don't even know what it
means and so uh
we use the word love to mean like or
preference or
or whatever but um when
you do have a a deeper
desire for the well-being of your
children over
you prioritize that over the well-being
of other children probably
subconsciously and consciously yeah so i
think that's just a function of having
spent more time caring for them that's
what i would argue
yeah but so you're saying if if you
lived in this situation right when they
were first born
and and ever all these other kids are
born at the same time or ten other kids
were born roughly the same time and you
were you had some sort of similar role
and
in all of their upbringing you would not
prioritize the biological preference
exactly you don't think you would no
absolutely wow well think about it so go
back to the hunter-gatherer model
they don't know which kids i mean they
barely know that sex causes babies right
they don't know
like the idea of paternal certainty is
very very new it's only once we had
genetic testing
could you even find out who the father
was right and still to this day they do
these large studies like this or who's
your daddy
study you know where they take a bunch
of people living in a like an apartment
complex and they just do dna testing
and then see oh is the person you think
is your father actually your father
right and then no about 20 to 30
of the time wow and so you know
you don't even what difference does it
make like paternal certainty has
probably done a lot of damage to
children if anything
right i agree with that what difference
does it make in our society we've been
told this idea has been propagated
that you especially as a man and i think
it's absurd
as a man you're you want to spread your
seed and carry on your lineage and all
that
how dumb is i mean it's it's so silly
because like as soon as i'm dead none of
it's going to matter to me why do i care
about like
um continuing the bloodline
what does that even mean they have my
same dna i don't i can't even explain
dna to you why would i even
like why am i so obsessed with this
right
and i think it's much more culture than
it is biology
the the obsession of my child
takes priority over the other children
in the community
and it seems to be that you are you're
saying yeah it's almost completely
societal
yeah i mean just look at you know i have
a three-year-old boy and he's got blonde
hair and chocolate brown eyes and he's
completely adorable but so is every
white caucasian baby looks exactly the
same like my wife almost jokes that you
could come home with the wrong one like
they all look the same to me
to be clear the british guest here is
not saying that white caucasian babies
are the cute babies
[Laughter]
just to clarify just to clarify yeah but
yeah i mean they're all they're all
adorable they make them adorable for a
reason right but what i'm saying is like
i'm not sure i'd be able to tell which
one was mine yeah
unless i had a dna test they all look
the same to me right right
and so um oh that's fascinating i mean
but there are some times where
you see someone there the spitting image
especially as they start to
reach you know uh pubescence and they're
post-pubescent
they really start to look like they're
their parents but even
kids quite often can look a lot like
their parent like one parent or the
other
yeah i mean and so so i don't know it
seems to me that there probably is some
sort of biological imperative maybe it's
it's mostly maternal
it seems that you can't yeah exactly you
almost know who the mama is like that's
that that's pretty obvious
right but i mean another thing i find
fascinating in hunter gatherer bands is
this idea of parable paternity and and
this is
the the idea that in order to make a
baby
you need the semen from more than one
man yes
yeah and this is like popped up in
independently in
different populations without them
having contact with each other
they believe in order to make a baby you
have to have sex with more than one man
and in order to inherit the attributes
of that man
you have to have sex with him right and
so you know if you want this guy because
he's tall and this guy because he's good
at
you know whatever it is like it so they
they don't even think
they think that you need more than one
man to make a baby like that's
so what you know our modern
understanding of genetics is really
changed everything
yeah right and so like what i find
fascinating about that is
it's not factually true obviously yeah
in fact
you can have sex with 10 men you're not
the baby's not going to get the
characteristics of nine of them it's
but there's a deeper truth there about
well if those 10 men are all
playing some role in their upbringing
then they are
by nurture going to get a lot of those
attributes
you know that those men exhibit right
completely agree
yeah so um so the unexpected thing and i
was going to finish that thought
was that so so you love the children
that you care for and the children that
you care for
love you but the the other really
important thing i think is that
you end up loving the people who care
for your children
and so if you spend a lot of time with
someone
and they're looking after your children
i think there's a really good chance
that you'll fall in love with them too
and this again is from gopnik and
you know that that why is that do you
think
so it allows childhood to take place so
that bond between you
allows the child a carefree assistant so
they can play and
learn how to be a human yeah there's an
evolutionary advantage i mean that's
always the answer right it's like
you know humans that did this were
slightly more successful at reproducing
than
humans that did not and that's why it
exists like there's no better
explanation than that
that's the answer but it's like an
unexpected gotcha i think if you're
spending a lot of time
living with people who are caring for
your children i think there's a really
good chance you'll fall in love with
them
wow